so with that
we have our next speaker
and he also had his wedding in ecuador
hmm we've already heard that one before
i wonder how that happened
everyone please welcome sebastian
to the stage
[Music]
thank you jared uh so yeah my name is
sebastian
um and i'm a data scientist of roon
room is a e-commerce company that sells
used cars
and deliver them to your home and today
i will be talking about
doubly robust estimation of causal
effects in
r so what is a causal inference
or what is causal inference in data
science uh so usually we
run a b test for reaching causal
conclusions or causal claims um
usually we would try to answer a
question that says will a
or b cause a better outcome where an
outcome can be a
better retention better client retention
um but sometimes we have data
on a and b but that was not generated to
a random expense
experiment we just happened to have it
and we still want to make some
causal claim about a versus b but
relying solely on this data won't allow
us to make correct causal claims about
you know the difference between a
and b and but we can use causal
inference
methods to try to estimate the causal
effect of
a versus b even from a non-random
experiment
so observational data and so what does
this talk about
um the goal of this talk is going to be
to estimate a causal effect when you
don't have data
from coming from a randomized experiment
and the first strategy we're going to
take or i'm going to explain is
regretting each observation by the
probability of receiving treatment a or
b
so that the data better approximates a
randomized experiment or
a b test the second strategy is just a
modeling
strategy in which we just model the
outcome directly with a linear model
and just figure out from there which
which one is better either am
or b and the third strategy actually
combines these
two ideas to form what is called a
doubly robust estimator
uh which i will explain um what this
means in a little bit
uh so first what is a causal effect
so actually causal effects are defined
in terms of a counterfactual difference
so what this counterfactual difference
is or
says is that on average receiving
treatment a
compared to receiving treatment b will
cause a difference in the outcome of
some delta
um and this this sounds uh you know very
similar to like just your typical
difference
but uh the fan that we want to know here
is that
y of a it's actually the outcome
if treatment a had been received and y
of b
is the outcome if treatment b had been
received so there are actually
counterfactual outcomes that said what
would have happened had i received a
or what would have happened had i
received b
and so this is a little bit different
than your usual mean difference so your
mean difference what it is is
the average difference in outcomes
between those receiving treatment a
and b so here we have mathematical
notation of the mean of a
minus the minimum of a b so the mean of
group a minus the mean of
group b um which you can always
calculate based on your data
and the the funny fact is that the
theory tells us that
in an a b tests or data coming from an a
b test
we can estimate the causal effect delta
that's based on counterfactual
outcomes which is what we really care
about
by simply using the differences of the
means uh and we can do this because of
randomization so in an a b test you
calculate the difference of your group a
and the difference in group b and
subtract that and that will be
equal to the counterfactual difference
of like if i had received treatment a
uh versus if i had received treatment b
what would have happened
uh unfortunately if you don't have
randomized data
this is not necessarily true like you
cannot simply look
at two differences of two groups to
arrive at a causal conclusion
so here i present a function which
simulates
data from a non-randomized experiment so
here this function simulates
observational data which is another
synonym for non-randomized
data and this data i first simulate a
variable x1
and x2 and put them together in this x
beta so i put them there together
and then i have a variable a which is my
treatment assignment variable which
equals one if
if i receive treatment a and equals zero
if i receive treatment b
and then what i'm really interested
about is this y which is my outcome
and my outcome depends on my variable x1
and x2
as well as my as my treatment assignment
a
and in front of a we have a coefficient
of 10
and so this thing here is actually a
causal effect so this is saying
if cut i receive a instead of b i get an
extra 10 of my outcome on average
uh unfortunately this is not a
randomized experiment it's not
it's not a a b test because the
probability
of assigning a or assigning one or zero
uh that probability that's defined here
as probable a depends on
our variables x one and x x two which
also happen
to uh um affect the outcome
so this is this is not a randomized
experiment and so this
um this makes it difficult to estimate
the causal effect
so how is that different from an a b
test so
i will replace the these two lines uh
the probability of a which depends on
the variables
x1 and x2 and the the
the when when i create this variable a i
create it such that it has a probability
a i will replace these two
lines with assigning a randomly one or
zero
just with a 50 50 chance uh so that that
that would be an a b test
and so if you have this data coming from
this simulation or from data
that you own uh the first thing that you
can try is this naive estimator
and the naive estimator is just again
the difference in the means between
group a and group b and here in
mathematical notation y is your outcome
and a
equals one for treatment a and one minus
a equals one for treatment b so it's
like the difference between group a and
b
and so you know we're trying to estimate
the true causal effect
based on counterfactuals with this
difference and so you know this is my
this this equation might look a little
complex but actually we can code it
really easily in r
creating this function naive estimator
and we fitted the data
and with the summarize function we
calculate the mean of group b
by just applying the mean function to
the outcome for those that receive
treatment b
and then we calculate the amino group a
for those that receive um
sorry we we calculate them in group a uh
by applying them into the outcome only
to those that receive treatment a and
then we take the difference inside the
the mutated statement to to arrive at
our
at our naive estimator um unfortunately
as i said before this naive estimator
fails because we don't have randomized
data so
in the difference of means does not
capture exclusively the effect of
treatment a or sorry of the treatment
variable on the outcome that mixes in
effects from other variables
as well and so here i've run with the
sim simulation simulating observational
data function
i've simulated this over 200 times and i
see that on average the naive estimator
um it's around 6.09 which is you know
pretty off from
from the horizontal black line of 10
which is the true causal effect so
so we are off we don't really succeed
using that estimator
and so in this case the first strategy
that you can try is the inverse
probability weighting
estimator and the intuition behind it is
that
in an experiment the probability of
receiving a treatment
are always equal across all the units so
in an a b test it would be 50 50 to
receive either a or b
and in a non-randomized experiment the
probability of receiving the treatment
depends on variables that
affect the outcome and if we knew
what these probabilities are we could
reweight our sample such that the data
will better match
a randomized experiment and and the
regulating scheme
what it does is that for units of the
experiment that were very likely to
receive the treatment
are weighting down and units that were
very unlikely to receive the treatment
are weighted up and this kind of
equalizes
your sample before analysis but in
reality we don't know what these
probabilities are so
we we're going to try to estimate them
using a model called the propensity
score model
and you know this all sounds very fancy
but the propensity score model is just a
logistic regression
of the probability of receiving the
treatment so if we code this in r
we can just make a propensity score
model function that
is really just hiding a logistic
regression inside of it with the
treatment as outcome
and then x1 and x2 has the variables
that we think affect
you know the the treatment uh receiving
the truth the probability of receiving
the treatment
so that's your propecity score model and
then what you're going to do is using
this propensity score model you're going
to calculate the probability of
receiving
treatment a which in here is defined by
this pi
in red and the probability of receiving
treatment b which is one minus pi
so in red here and and you in this form
you make the inverse probability
weighted estimator
which was the same as the naive
estimator but now you've
weighed it down by the probability of
receiving treatment a if you happen to
receive treatment a
a or waiting down by the probability of
receiving treatment b if you receive
treatment b
and if this looks a little complicated
again you can just code it
super fast in one function that i have
named here inverse
probability weighting estimator and you
fit to this function the data
and your propensity score model your
logistic regression
so in the first mutate statement um you
calculate the probability of receiving
treatment a with the predict function
and then you're going to calculate once
again the the mean of group b
and the mean on group a that you're
going to weight
each observation uh by the probability
of receiving the treatment so one minus
prob is the probability of receiving
treatment b and for
group a you divide everything by the
probability of receiving treatment
and then at the end in the last mutated
statement you can take the difference
between these two means to arrive at
your ipw estimator um and how does this
estimator perform so we see from these
hundreds of simulations that
um on average the ipw estimator is
around
10.04 which is really close to the
the true causal effect of 10. so it
performs pretty well
but you know this strategy could fail
and so
let's say in the propensity score model
definition i forgot like variable two
you know
or it could be another thing like i
don't i don't i don't know i have to
include it so i messed it up
uh so then the previous light wouldn't
look as nice so i will i will get a
a incorrect estimator as well but that's
okay you can
if you think that's the case you can try
a second strategy which is model the
outcome
and i feel like this strategy is sort of
like the default strategy of a data
scientist
and you will just you know create a
linear model
your your outcome is your y and then
that model depends on your variable x1
and x2 and your variable a for treatment
assignment
and the coefficient of a uh the delta in
front of a
that will be your estimator of the
causal effect and so
easy again you can create a function
called mean outcome model which inside
you can
just cons contains this definition of
this model that depends on
his linear regression that has your
outcome and which depends on x1 x2 and
the treatment indicator
and then you can create this other
function outcome model estimator
which you fitted the data then creates
this model
and then using the summary function it
recovers the coefficient of treatment to
get this delta that
i've mentioned above and that's easy
to do and then if we run this over many
simulations we again see that
on average it's 9.99 so it gets really
close to the true causal effect of that
so
you know that that's great um but again
this
this model could also fail we could have
forgotten another of our variables and
then the previous strategy wouldn't work
so well
right so that i mean that's kind of
obvious right
um so what could we do instead so
there's this idea
of combining both approaches so strategy
one and strategy two so
um the idea behind this is that if your
logistic regression model for the
propensity score is incorrect the first
strategy you know
won't work if your linear regression for
your outcome model is incorrect
is the second strategy will not work um
but if you combine both approaches
actually it happens that you just need
either ones or just one of them to work
or you just need one of them to be
correct uh for your
estimator to be cr to work but you don't
need both models to be correct
so what this means is as a data
scientist as a data scientist you have
one out of two
chances to get the correct answer
and and so this this property is is what
is called the
do doubly robustness property
and so you know this this is this can
also fail that is less likely to do so
because now you're relying but on a
linear regression and a
logistic regression which you know gives
you a higher chance to be successful
and so here i have the equation of what
the double
robust estimator is and i've highlighted
in red what we've added to the
inverse probability weighted estimator
um
and so in red we see that in parenthesis
we have the
the treatment variable which you
subtract your
your your probability prediction from
your propensity score model
and you multiply that this mu which is
just the
the prediction from your linear model so
here's where the linear model comes from
and so you know in the literature they
say that the term in red
is set to augment the inverse
probability weighted estimator
and the theory tells us that this
estimator will work
as long so it will recover the true
causal effect as long as either the
logistic regression for capacity score
model is correct
or the linear regression for the outcome
model is correct
but you don't need both of them to be
correct at the same time
and you know if you know the previous
equations seem a little bit
complex even got more complicated but we
can write it very sustainably in one
function
uh here called double rupaus estimator
and to this function you feed the data
the the logistic regression for the
propensity score model and the linear
model for the mean outcome model
and inside the first mutate statement
you again calculate the probability of
receiving treatment
a with the predict function on the
logistic regression you
calculate a prediction of your outcome
based on your
on your linear regression again with the
prediction function
the predict function and then you
calculate this augmented term
which is just your treatment minus your
probability
times the prediction of the linear model
and then inside the summarized statement
you calculate the mean
for outcome mean for group b
which again you just take the mean of
the outcome for that for that group
subtract this augmented term and
everything you divide
y minus prop which is the probability of
receiving treatment b
and you do the same for for group a you
calculate the mean of group a by
taking the outcome subtracting the
augmented part and dividing by the
probability of receiving treatment a
and then in the last mutated statement
we just take the difference between
these two means
to arrive at the double robust estimator
of the causal effects
um so how does this estimator perform so
we see in this simulation again
we could simulate it hundreds of times
and we see that on average
uh we get 10 10.1 which is really close
to the causal effect
of 10. um but now as an example uh i'll
run this simulation again
but now i'll feed the estimator uh a
incorrect propensity score model where
like i i remove one of the variables
that
you should have and so how does this
perform
um so here when the propensity score is
incorrect we see
we we have some decay in the performance
but it still works pretty well so on
average the double robot's estimator is
10.49 which is pretty close to the
true causal effect of 10. and likewise
um let's say we fix the propensity score
model
but now the logit the linear model is
incorrect so i remove one of the
variables that i should include
in there and we run this simulation and
so we see that the double robust
estimator
still performs fairly well where on
average
on average this estimator is 10.38 which
is again
still pretty close to the true causal
effect of
of 10. so in conclusion
what i want you to take out of my talk
is that if you have no randomized data
you cannot simply calculate the
difference in means
between group a and group b to estimate
the causal effect
you have you know a few strategies that
you can try so the first one you can try
the inverse probability weighted
estimator
based on a logistic regression of the
probability of receiving the treatment
the second thing that you could do is
you can model the outcome based on a
linear model
with the confounding which includes the
confounded variables as well as the
treatment assignment variable
or you can combine these two strategies
uh to use the doubly robust estimator
which will work
as long as either the logistic
regression or the or the linear
regression are correct
but you don't need both of them to be
correct in order for this estimator to
work
uh yeah so that's the conclusion of my
talk and
if you're interested in learning more i
highly recommend to read this uh
this paper by marie davidian on
weighting propensity score in estimation
of causal treatment effects a super
simple paper and basically my talk was
based on on this paper
um but it was based on this paper and
yeah
i wanted to thank um lumila yanda my
wife
for listening to my talk 10 times and i
would also like to
thank the room data team for listening
to my talk once
thank you and so the mystery solved why
we had two speakers who
had a wedding in ecuador thank you very
much for that talk
uh causal inferences so much
is so hot right now so it's good to have
that talk we'll have actually another
causal inference talk coming up tomorrow